>>> THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF THE FEDERAL JUDGE WHO
REPORTEDLY SIGNED OFF ON THE
WARRANT TO SEARCH MAR-A-LAGO.
ONLINE VIOLENT RHETORIC
PROMPTING A COURT IN FLORIDA TO
REMOVE THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
MAGISTRATE JUDGE LINKED BY SOME
MEDIA OUTLETS TO THAT WARRANT.
POSTED ON PRO TRUMP WEBSITES
HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR THE
JUDGE'S HOME ADDRESS TO BE
SHARED ONLINE.
ANOTHER FOCUS OF THE THREATS,
THE FBI.
THE BUREAU'S DIRECTOR SPEAKING
TO REPORTERS DIRECTLY ADDRESSED
THE SAFETY OF THESE AGENTS.
LISTEN.
>> I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT
VIOLENCE AND THREATS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ANY THREATS MADE AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE FBI, AS WITH
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, ARE
DEPLORABLE AND DANGEROUS.
>> CNN'S DONIE O'SULLIVAN HAS
BEEN REPORTING ON THIS VIOLENT
RHETORIC.
DONIE, YOU TRACKED THIS STUFF
CLOSELY.
YOU READ SOME OF IT AS QUITE
DISTURBING.
GO INTO THE DETAILS AND HELP ME
WITH THE CONTEXT.
IS THIS LOUDER, MORE THREATENING
PRIOR TO JANUARY 6th OR ABOUT
THE SAME?
>> IT'S VERY, VERY HARD TO
MEASURE THESE THINGS
QUANTITATIVELY.
BUT WHAT WE CAN SAY IS RIGHT
AFTER NEWS OF THAT FBI SEARCH ON
MAR-A-LAGO BROKE ON MONDAY, WE
SAW AN IMMEDIATE SPIKE IN
VIOLENT RHETORIC.
IF WE CAN BRING BACK UP THAT
WEBSITE, THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF FLORIDA COURT'S WEBSITE.
U UP UNTIL SOMETIME TUESDAY
EVENING, THERE WAS A PROFILE OF
A JUDGE ON THAT SITE WITH
CONTACT DETAILS FOR THE JUDGE.
THE JUDGE'S OFFICE CLERKS, ET
CETERA.
THAT HAD TO BE TAKEN DOWN FROM
THAT WEBSITE BECAUSE THERE WERE
SO MANY PEOPLE ON THESE
PLATFORMS CALLING FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST THAT JUDGE.
OF COURSE, IT DOESN'T JUST
RELATE TO THE JUDGE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
THREATENING MESSAGES AND THE
RHETORIC PLAYED OUT ONLINE.
SOMEBODY JUST POSTED LOCK AND
LOAD IN RELATION TO THE
MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH.
KILL ALL FEDS.
SOMEBODY ELSE SAYING, I'M JUST
GOING TO SAY IT.
GARLAND NEEDS TO BE
ASSASSINATED.
SIMPLE AS THAT.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
TELL THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
SERIOUS THREAT, SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT RESULT IN REAL WORLD
VIOLENCE AND PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
TALKING A BIG GAME ON THE
INTERNET.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS ON THESE
VERY, VERY SAME FORUMS, THIS IS
WHERE PLANNING FOR JANUARY 6th,
THIS IS WHERE VIOLENT RHETORIC
IN THE LEAD-UP TO JANUARY 6th
WAS ALL PLAYING OUT.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO WENT TO THE
CAPITOL AND COMMITTED VIOLENCE
THAT DAY WERE ON THESE FORUMS.
>> DONIE O'SULLIVAN, THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING ME, CNN'S MELANIE
ZANONA, TIA MITCHELL OF THE
ATLANTA JOURNAL CONSTITUTION.
THE LAST POINT THERE, DONIE IS
SMART, THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
YOU CAN'T QUANTITY STATE, IS
THERE MORE OR LESS?
IS IT ABOUT THE SAME.
FOR THE POLITICAL LEADERS USING
STRIDENT LANGUAGE THEMSELVES,
AND THEY WOULD SAY THEY'RE NOT
CALLING FOR VIOLENCE, WE HAVE
SEEN THE CAUSE AND EFFECT OF
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE ELECTION
BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO STRIKING TO
HEAR THIS HARSH RHETORIC.
>> THESE CONCERNS ARE NOT
UNFOUNDED.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN
McTHAR THINK NOT ONLY NOT
CONDEMNING THE VIOLENCE, BUT
ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
BE LOUD AND SPEAK OUT.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN CALLING FOR
VIOLENCE, BUT WE'VE SEEN WHAT
FEEDING INTO CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND RILING UP THE BASE CAN DO AS
WITH JANUARY 6th.
YOU HAVE STEVE SCALISE ALLEGING
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE THAT THESE
AGENTS WENT ROGUE.
YOU ALSO HAVE OTHER REPUBLICANS
ACTIVELY SPREADING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT FBI AGENTS
PLANTING EVIDENCE.
SO IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT AN
UNFOUNDED CONCERN ABOUT
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
>> WE CAN SHOW YOU SOME OF THE
WORDS.
PAUL GOSAR, NOTED CONSPIRACY
THEORIST FROM ARIZONA, WE MUST
DESTROY THE FBI.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, THESE
ARE THE TYPE OF THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN COUNTRIES DURING CIVIL
WAR.
AND THERE'S MORE AND MORE.
IT IS STRIKING.
>> IT'S STRIKING.
BEYOND THE GOSAR AND TAYLOR
GREENE STUFF, THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN THIS KIND OF RHETORIC BUILT
INTO THE RIGHT WEEK.
IN THE 1990s, YOU COULD FIND
PEOPLE THAT BELIEVED THE U.N.
INVASION FORCE WAS ON ITS WAY,
THE BLACK HELICOPTERS COMING FOR
AMERICANS, FIND PEOPLE WHO
REFERRED TO AT AS GOVERNMENT
THUGS.
IT WAS THE GOSARS, IT WASN'T THE
MORE CENTRAL LEADERSHIP OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THAT'S BEEN THE F EVOLUTION.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO DRAMATIC.
SITTING SENATORS COMING OUT AND
SAYING THE FBI IS SCHEMING TO
PUT TRUMP IN FRONT OF A FIRING
SQUAD.
SITTING SENATORS TALKING ABOUT,
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER,
TALKING ABOUT PLANTED EVIDENCE.
WHAT'S SO STRIKING, IT'S NOT
SOME RANDOM INTERNET CHAT FORUM.
IT'S THE LEADING LIGHTS OF A
MAJOR POLITICAL PARTY.
>> McCARTHY IS USING THIS AS A
RALLYING CRY FOR HIS PARTY,
TRYING TO SCORE POINTS WITH
TRUMP WORLD, HE'S FUND-RAISING
OFF THIS.
>> I HOLD THIS UP.
IT'S HARD TO SEE AT HOME.
THIS IS AN ADORING KEVIN
McCARTHY LOOKING AT DONALD
TRUMP.
HE GOES ON TO TALK ABOUT HOW
FURIOUS HE IS THE DOJ HAS BEEN
WEAPONIZED.
WHAT YOU CHOOSE TO DO OR CHOOSE
NOT TO DO AT THIS MOMENT WILL
DETERMINE EVERYTHING.
HE MEANS SEND ME MONEY.
BUT THEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE PRO TRUMP WEBSITES, ONE
POST HERE, ARE WE NOT IN A COLD
CIVIL WAR AT THIS POINT?
IT IS THEIR JOB IN LEADERSHIP TO
UNDERSTAND THAT'S OUT THERE AND
TO CHOOSE THEIR WORDS CAREFULLY.
BUT THEY CHOOSE NOT TO.
>> TO MELANIE'S POINT, I THINK
THEY BELIEVE THAT RHETORIC
AROUND A CIVIL WAR, RHETORIC
AROUND PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
SPREADING CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND MISLEADING INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THIS WAS, WHICH WAS JUST A
SEARCH WARRANT.
IF HE DID NOTHING WRONG, THEN
YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT NOTHING
WOULD COME OF IT.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS LANGUAGE
WILL BENEFIT THEM.
I THINK THEY BELIEVE THIS
LANGUAGE WILL HELP DISTRACT FROM
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN CELEBRATING
RECENTLY.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THEY
BELIEVE THIS LANGUAGE IS WHAT
THEIR BASE WANTS TO HEAR.
IS WHAT THEIR BASE BELIEVES.
THEY BELIEVE THIS LANGUAGE WILL
KEEP THEM IN POWER.
BUT I WONDER IF THEY THINK ABOUT
TO WHAT END.
>> DO THEY THINK ABOUT THEIR
COLLEAGUES.
AFTER TEN HOUSE REPUBLICANS
VOTED TO IMPEACH TRUMP, MANY
RECEIVED THREATS.
THIS IS ERIC SWALWELL.
REPUBLICANS DON'T LIKE ERIC
SWALWELL, THEY THINK HE WAS ON
THE IMPEACHMENT COMMITTEES AND
WAS OVER AGGRESSIVE.
YOU'RE ENTITLED TO YOUR
POLITICAL OPINION ABOUT THAT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT ABOUT HIS
WIFE AND HIS CHILDREN WHEN THIS
COMES IN.
>> SWALWELL IS A WORTHLESS BEES
OF [ BLEEP ].
CUT HIS WIFE'S HEAD OFF.
CUT HIS KID'S HEAD OFF.
>> WHEN YOU KNOW THIS IS OUT
HERE.
WHEN WE WATCH TWHAPD ON JANUARY
6th, IT SHOULD BE INCUMBENT ON
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING PEOPLE IN
OUR BUSINESS, CHOOSE YOUR WORDS
CAREFULLY.
>> DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
COMPLICATED CONCLUSION TO REACH.
>> I THINK THERE'S ONE OTHER
ELEMENT TO WHAT YOU JUST SAID
WHICH IS A LOT OF THESE FOLKS
WORRY ABOUT THE COST OF NOT
USING THIS RHETORIC BECAUSE THE
EXPECTATION IS BUILT IN SO MUCH
INTO THE TRUMP WORLD, THAT THIS
IS THE NATURAL AND NECESSARY
RESPONSE.
KEVIN McCARTHY'S FIRST RESPONSE
WAS, WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
HEARINGS.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WASH WITH A
LOT OF THE TRUMPLAND PEOPLE OUT
THERE MAKING THESE MORE
INCENDIARY COMMENTS.